this lecture the aim of this lecture is
improving
position of your pieces of course it's
not so easy to understand that case
positional from positional point of view
you have to take a que about your pieces
of time what you actually do in the
opening okay for example you play E 4 E
5 Bishop c4 Knight f3 you're improving
position of your pieces here I agree
right to move his game diamond off
against the veto
1959 in Dresden I suppose it will be it
was an early Olympiad yeah Sophocles so
right to move and White has to decide in
this position I'll play so and white
already developed all pieces you can see
the strong bishop on a 3G to knight on a
space 3 C 3 okay white cannot develop
the Queen because black has very strong
knight on d4 but white can improve
position of one of the night
so I would like to explain you when you
want to advance your pieces you'll find
the best square for your piece first of
all you take a look on the board and you
can imagine the way your piece will stay
better so you can see last move I
suppose black plate 94 why I want after
changed night hd4 take this bone and
trailer gee organized for the bishop and
somewhere geez 395 black is absolute
fine
so the second thread somewhere
efore taken unless we take only one okay
what has to be careful but white can
improve position of Knight f3 could you
find the place on a board where we can
put this night it big threads for black
position
just imagine d3 and what is the fret
okay
sorry which to air is cc5 okay
you have to be more brave you can say
not d3 but see five square
it's absolute all right square for a
white knight on f3 so and what we can to
do with very strong knight on d4
he's three yeah absolutely right if we
can push this night away okay go f6f-5
White has more space it means white has
saved more pieces on the board first of
all and second understand what if our
night come on c5 white is certainly
better because we are open our Bishop
from g2 pushing on green side attacking
on b7 okay what else so you can find
white move easier not so easy okay
knight Knight g5 yes 95 it was her idea
95 yes absolute right now g5 has
happened in a game okay
95 black replies with Ruby 8 so Roxy
fire
Roxy one happened first of all just
provoke something like h6 black is
nothing to do because white is any
moment can play 94 and 95 here h6 94
so black plays f5 in this position how
you can evaluate this move fi has good
move a bad move for a rich probably not
good not bad not good not so good ok
yeah your absolute right here f5 just
opened the yoga not a 2g8 one moment
here you can use it for for the Queen
when you play 95 phase 323 give each
exam something so in this position black
has to play d6 what is the absolute
right move b6 just b6 is 396 Bishop
takes seven rook takes is 795 what
happens if I'll take on d5
Knight f6 simple a cake Renea rogue g7
night before Queen 893 okay white white
has advantage but not a decisive
advantage in this position so haven't f5
f5 attacking our knight on e4 not
history immediately please don't forget
about unite only 495 Mystics 96 I just
shortly show you what happened in the
game it's not demo power lecture
beta X a six now White has a very strong
Bishop and very strong pawn on a six if
someday one day night comes on b5 and
the night Knight can take immediately on
a seven in n games okay it's absolutely
inflect so c 505 E for history if you
have two bishops and especially such Tom
Bishop on Zito and you're open and close
will be shop you can try the open with
Bishop immediately okay it's absolute
right idea almost in all positions
district is right move 95 night XD 5
into x t5 8 x d6 some tactical
complications but on the end ok you can
see white can promote the pawn a pawn
very strong and now I can also explain
the principle of two weaknesses so
what happened in this position white has
a very strong phone in this moment very
strong phone and a six is one break
weakness the second weakness if somebody
can say me what is the second witness of
black position it was okay if two
removes black can take a phone protect
everything okay black is okay but right
now we have two witnesses and we can use
it with white pieces no no I don't ask
about the moose
I ask about the witnesses a6v we have
very strong pawn on e6 okay g6 only for
very very very weak bones and the most
witnesses kink okay it's just big phone
but we if their take on e4 and attack in
the white squares black cannot survive
in such position the second witness is
black king just about ok queen g4 white
not try to protect a6 we use the time to
attack the second witness when the black
take about a six pawn this is the
principle to weaknesses is very
important for the chest queen is 6 Queen
e2 now okay now okay if black Queen come
back we can protect and push the our
iPhone Queen six Queen C for check King
h8 look everyone so what black can to do
in this position
rookie 7 we have to hold a phone and
steal the second witness black in
college aid still here Roxy to buy
simple double underhook on differ
ok 5 rook CD 2
brilliant technique huh b5 Queen f7 28
black has no time to take on a a six
because I don't know many okay Ruby a
check and Queen g8 mate what do you see
Queen 8 a 7 ok small tactical tricks
here twin B 7 and troop the 7 okay game
over
take everything here ok
okay the second example helping happened
between Kramnik who plays with with
white pieces and regimes VI cancer
all right to move in this position and
okay so if you play Queen e2 I will take
on e3 how your wrecked
okay that's that's okay your proposed is
no here I will take here ministry okay
small more the less fine for black okay
ready no all looks and after okay if you
play so Queenie 222 sorry takes takes
between f4 model recipe now we are
talked about before square we have to
play with night but but we can see the
next black move should be
Rotech III
yes yes exactly 91 the right idea here
if black takes on history yes take of
the night here take or denied bring
tonight on very strong position and
after our dear Queen before or 95 ok
many many ideas ok if for example 24 we
can play twin before yeah
no actually it not happened in the game
the agency reply g6 in this position
just prevent rook takes three night it
takes three into one moment 94 just make
service solid move protect the f5 Square
Kramnik reply with Bishop sorry Queen
Queen before 97 and now very interesting
a very interesting solution that's very
concrete
you can see a bishop on c6 it's not so
good yeah but this Bishop protect all
pawns around
Bishop b5 Bishop b5 here you repeat the
columbic idea great this would be five
now black cannot hold a four and d5 okay
white can play 93 back and take pawn on
e4 and e5 so this actually happened in
the game we should be 5 root X is 3
Knight X is 3 now Knight f6 Bishop take
a fall okay such level like a Kramnik
has one pound up usually it's enough
advantage to lead the game to the win
easily I just show you what happened in
a game very shortly okay rookie for
white start to trade all pieces and
after we we have the Miss extra pound on
Queen side towards the palms and okay
it's not perpetual here okay 27 black
resigns because 25 coming Eve black
takes on default what will happen 23
yeah absolute right it win in pawn and
game okay go ahead
but please keep in your mind okay how
Kramnik use with weaknesses on a black
squares
sometimes your start calculation the
lines like Bishop b12 industry trying to
do domain but you can find a very weak
squares and you can replace your pieces
and take simple bones only for salad or
d5 I don't know it might be easier to
beat your opponent in such case not to
give you might immediately
I'm understand you like to give the
media all of you when I play the bridge
games everybody pay fo c 5d for it was
my childhood gambit Morrigan i play with
white pieces many times even a plate in
similar on against Kasparov such gambit
and I had a very good chance to beat him
move for 16 or 17 pot okay
hit escape after he had extra piece and
draw on the end yeah it was in civil
tongue but nowadays with computers which
is just device the very strong advice is
give evaluation what will come but more
a gambit not so solid it means almost
refuted black has many ways ok not many
ways to three ways how to keep the phone
and get advantage so always in the high
level the grandmasters top to play but
you can play easily no problem
okay is a very common position yeah
from a rail OPA so from Italian game ok
black to move can you find after two
previous examples okay you can
understand now yeah moving midnight yeah
Oh examples how you can play with night
how we can improve position of our night
and what is idea of a movement of course
hmm
I'm sorry black to move black you have
to play play with black night yeah okay
and so the idea mmm
it's a tactical idea attacking something
attacking keen katakan foam but what a
strategical idea after night 896 is
absolute right school d-file
and okay and the main idea I would like
to hear the main idea f5 yes absolute
right we are replaced night on d6 and
play after King h8 and somewhere you can
see we can play f5 open F file
we are developed we all develop the
Bishop from c8 in one move Bishop days
f5 and just pushing on f2 it's not
common idea in such position and such
position ok most of the player play ok
27 Bishop e6 trying to actualize it
position maybe it's it's ok
but after Queen is 705 Bishop basics
bishop history change OB shows Bishop
takes 3 between take is 3 Bishop e6
white letters small small advantage
because the phone on a5 and block the
Queen side and ok somewhere be 493 ok 95
very close to equalizing but you know
cuz Valerie found this very interesting
idea 98
Wyatt replies very aggressive replace
very aggressive right place mystery in
this position after the game of course
if you understand what happened in the
game you will choose the other move here
okay Bishop III was more safe in this
position Bishop III takes takes 90 see
Bishop e2 okay in this position black
slightly better because Knight 1 d6 okay
I can play Bishop e6 Queen d7 on Queen
f6 but Kraken Kraken cause opponent of
cache belief place be 396 Bishop e3 King
catch 8 I talked about this idea in
cached the IDF 592 white also developed
the pieces okay
great normal but f5 talent and position
became unpleasant for White Queen e2
Queen f6
Bishop these three
and how we can continue attack okay
f4 f4 f4 g5 okay you can place your con
g8 and we have protect CFO square white
bishop cannot go and see fault
because we can take midnight and play G
for any case f4 Knight f3 g 5c for g4
its first line here hdhd for Bishop to
g4
see five okay it looks like black lost
the game yeah was the piece button
grandmasters game okay you can find it
not true in this position when cash the
left plate g5 he is already knows he
sacrificed the piece and could somebody
find the tactical idea for four black in
this position
knight of seven you don't need a bishop
on v6 but we play knight of seven ig5
and trying to give him a knight of seven
and B should be - okay I will show you
what will happen if white takes with
Bishop on t 695 Bishop takes a fate yeah
it's too greedy night X is three g2 x f3
Bishop h3 Otis Fred fred is Quincy -
mate on Zito and white cannot survive if
kinkajou
how we can the play
yeah okay faith we can support a Conniff
idea if kin takes on h3 green h6 check
and mate
immediately and thread Queen h4
okay what happened in the game night
ostrich horse if take tech Knight f6
Bishop b2 that contain the game Bishop
takes e5 okay the rest is not so
interesting Bishop c4 Knight g5 Bishop
takes e5 Knight x3 takes takes takes now
tactical trick again
roj it I feel it's not so good but okay
let's let's check it move rotate bishop
DJ ROC the8 okay your idea queen of
story with Algeria
I'm Rekha so I am reply with Queen 25
27:23 still no mate yeah yeah ugh
I mean instead of fruit Jade instead of
rope jgc okay f3 yes as soon as possible
yeah okay it's happened in the game but
I would like to ask if somebody see this
move Bishop takes f2
it just means immediately now if King
test has to take away Queen give check
on d4 with the problem you cannot go on
Iran because you're hanging on a one in
key to Ministry and troop the agent if
you take if you play Bishop g5 I can
take on e4 and pin and take on d5 and
made them very soon okay but f3 is also
key yeah
f3 what actually happened in the game a
queen is it no it's okay we need for
finish three takes takes okay
you can just say one nice move and next
move
what will be the next move takes what
okay so now the head is okay so ready 1
1 hour left
okay make a small break 5 minute and we
are continuing with Bishop Treyarch and
the bishop Rock may be queen
OC and in the end we will be king
improver position of the king